attention descendants cast we're super
excited to see you guys wrap up the
franchise this summer but can all of you
please do friends forever you're just
the best movie cast ever and are
seriously friendship goals we've seen
you dance
seeing laugh and cry and now it looks
like it's our time to shed a tear or two
we love the cast of descendants three
there are awesome actors and even better
people you won't believe how close they
are in real life keep watching to find
out some awesome facts about the stars
of the third movie parlez-vous francais
it's hard to imagine mal being played by
anyone other than dub Cameron but here's
something you may not know about her
even though she was born in Seattle Dov
his part French not only does she have
Parisian ancestors but she's also fluent
in French
strike a pose money isn't the only one
who thinks je is good looking booboo
Stewart is a total heartthrob and he was
one cute kid too Jay actually got his
started modeling when he was just 10
years old it opened up a whole world of
entertainment to him total newbie Sophia
Carson is such an amazing actress from
the moment we saw her as evey we were
huge fans she seemed like such a pro at
acting in the first Descendants movie
but it was actually her first movie role
ever and she had only appeared on three
TV shows before break it down the cast
did descendant 3 has done some
incredible dance scenes but Carlos takes
it to a whole new level Cameron Boyce
loves to breakdance and he's super good
at it he even started a breakdancing
crew with his friends called X mob like
mother like daughter
she may be a villain but we love uma in
china anne mcclain does such a great job
singing and acting but she comes by it
naturally her mom Chantal is a singer
and songwriter who has also done some
acting
[Music]
Broadway kings
Cheyenne Jackson plays Hades in the new
movie he's got a lot of acting credits
but his real love is Broadway he has won
a ton of awards for his plays
these include Xanadu and all shook up we
can't wait to meet Hades soon
Dizzy's favorite food
we're totally obsessed with Anna
Cathcart she's sassy and stylish and
totally relatable and I told sweety high
that she can't live without french fries
and we can't say we really blame her
french fries for the wind dance stars
there's no doubt that Harry hook was one
of the best new characters in the second
film and Thomas Doherty can act sing and
dance he attended the mga Academy of
Performing Arts in Scotland he was
trained in contemporary dance jazz hip
hop and ballet he's got some serious
moves the land down under King then is a
much better ruler than his mom and dad
we just love Ben's character but we were
shocked to find out that Mitchell hope
is actually Australian something
happened to me when I was on the aisle
with uma he does a really convincing
American accent in The Descendants
movies one big family we're super
excited to see Jada Murray plays Celia
facili a in descendant 3
is she good is she evil we don't know
data comes from a huge family did you
know that she's the youngest of nine
siblings wow that's a lot of kids each
blonde
Carlos is super recognizable by his
bleached blond hair but it's not a wig
Malon Evie may wear wigs for their
characters but human voice actually
bleached his hair bleaching can be rough
on your hair so we think that is serious
dedication if the shoe feds
Melanie via our friendship goals and
dove Cameron and Sophia Carson are good
friends too
but they have more in common than you
might think they were the same size shoe
dub will totally be borrowing Sofia's
wicked booties from the d3 trailer
Prince J the casting of The Descendants
movies are perfect it's hard to imagine
anyone else in these roles but booboo
Stewart originally auditioned for the
role of Ben we're sure he would have
been great but we're happy he's a --vk
the dedicated mermaid
china anne mcclain is one dedicated
actress she plays the daughter of Ursula
she did some serious research for her
role she watched The Little Mermaid at
least 20 times to prepare it definitely
paid off lots of languages Eevee is
brilliant and so is the actress who
plays ER
Sophia Carson can speak three languages
she's fluent in English Spanish and
French that is seriously impressive do
you think she and Dev speak in French on
set matching tattoos when you're filming
a movie like descendants you get pretty
close to your co-stars the pirate vks
are no exception china anne mcclain
Thomas Doherty and Dylan play fair got
matching incurred tattoos some of the
dancers from umas shifted to chillin
like a vegan Audrey may be mean she
might even turn evil in the third movie
but Sarah Jeffery definitely isn't she
loves animals in fact she's vegan she
also works with campaigns to help end
animal cruelty
we're glad she's not like Audrey in real
life almost married Duff Cameron used to
date Ryan McCartney he was her co-star
on Liv and Maddie things got really
serious between the two they were
engaged for a while before they broke up
now dev is dating Thomas Doherty and
they're so cute together
mal secret one of the big reveals in
descendants three is who Mouse daddies
but this was no secret to dev she was in
on the truth about mouths father from
the very beginning we wonder what other
characters knew the big reveal before
they saw the script real-life besties
the cast of descendants is super close
in real life Dov and Sophia late-onset
after their last scene together just
reminiscing then the whole cast had a
big junk food party and cried together
on the last night we hope they all act
together again in the future
tell us how excited you are to see the
new movie in the comments thanks for
watching the things give this video a
big thumbs up and don't forget to
subscribe we'll catch you next time
[Music]